et puis un joli cadeau pour le musée
d'orsay le musée des beaux-arts de lille
qui s'enrichissent de deux oeuvres
importantes l'une d'edouard manet berthe
morisot à l'éventail et l'autre
d'auguste renoir l'enfant au chat ses
oeuvres ont été reçus par l'état en
dation l'occasion de rappeler que la
procédure dation permet à déshériter de
s'acquitter des droits de succession par
la remise de tableaux commentaires
georges bigot etienne gicquel cette
petite fille peinte par renoir en 1887
s'appelle julie manet elle est la nièce
de l'illustre edouard manet son portrait
a toujours été conservé dans sa famille
par son fils aîné puis par la veuve de
celui ci dont on règle aujourd'hui la
succession renoir en cette période la
subissent l influence dingue
madame la ministre de la culture est
satisfaite de voir entrer cette oeuvre
majeure au musée d'orsay
quant à pierre mauroy il se trouve là
c'est pour recevoir au nom du musée des
beaux-arts de lille un splendide
portrait de berthe morisot par manet
berthe morisot était le modèle favori
d'edouard manet mais c'est son frère
eugène man et qu'elle épousera pour
donner naissance à la petite julie dont
nous avons vu le portrait peint par
renoir
au total les deux oeuvres représentent
67 millions de francs de droits de
succession que les héritiers
d'aujourd'hui n'auront pas à payer